yeah we got Lexi here today people do
Lexi you know I always bring my friends
on but I was like bring one of Jerry's
friends on said hey and she's full
Italian represent he is always a plus
they say full Italians but the sexiest
gun ain't that right Lexi they say it's
a talented you see I thought it'd be
cool to have her on too because she
didn't actually see the first spider-man
it should be a good standalone film
though you know so I was like
interesting compelling I like having you
want well I do yeah that's what James
Cameron said hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Jerry I'm Lexie two reasons to see where
we give you reasons to sing and not to
see the amazing spider-man
so let's wipe sling together or
something cool like that all right guys
we're gonna have a little spoiler talk
here because there are plenty of
spoilers to cover surprisingly again
after they released like 90 minutes
worth of exclusive footage yeah well
this movie okay right rhinos in this
film for like five minutes they didn't
really give him much to do but something
about Paul Giamatti he looks the part
but the sound of him yeah something
about his performance I'm not quite
buying it seems like he's really acting
he is a little more akin to one of the
other spider-man movies than yeah that's
probably it
those [ __ ] makeup bars this film is
really setting out for the sinister six
yeah apparently everyone comes from law
school that start Norman Osborn is the
root of all also at the end the little
boy was there and don't you cuz he's a
little boy Rhino guys just like who is
this funny and I'm just this earring do
nothing even when Spiderman shows up and
I'm not gonna like shoot spider-man even
though this is like the perfect
opportunity because he's gonna protect
the little boy I'm gonna not be a
criminal
problems actually with this film the
more I think about it like I like them
so I do like the film a lot I go back
and forth a lot when I think about
certain things I did feel this movie
could have had more of an emotional
effect overall like more impact if there
wasn't so much going on you got Peter
and when trying to work things out then
you got electro who kind of just like
the first 30 minutes like there's a lot
of focus on Max and then Max is kind of
just gone and then he's like we're gonna
bring him back towards the finale to
have a cool finale Harry Osborn trying
to save his life and Peter and Harry and
then Peter and apni and Peter's trying
to figure out his past which really
wasn't a big payoff to me actually it
was like what did he really learn that
was so different well it isn't in any
way challenging it's like oh yeah Ben
Parker was a great guy they're not bad
Parker whatever his dad's name Richard
Parker Richard Parker was a good guy
after all
Nick Parker yeah tricky dick partners
yeah names dick pocket kid it was cool
like learning about like oh it's his
human blood and stuff but still I was
like what a lot of focus on this just to
learn that Jeremy Johnson said it best
actually just one of the Oscorp is still
bad we didn't really learn much else
I like the acting a lot I was moved
enough by it but it could have been more
powerful that moment where spider-man
shows up in front of Harry and he's like
hey I'm not gonna give you my blood and
then you know he just goes all Scarface
on him again it's just a lot of this
stuff man I've been played okay because
they seemed played well to me cuz it was
like I felt uncomfortable like to me
everything just played well everything
played good but I was like a lot of this
stuff could have been great if I didn't
have to keep shifting my focus so much I
liked that because the emotional stuff
was played very real and very
authentically so you kind of see what
was going on in spider-man's life and he
has these like intense experiences in
these fights and stuff the crap makes
him identifiable to us still takes over
and you know and that's still you know
plagues him in the long run like every
day he looks at this you know
the briefcase of his dad and you know
what's bothering him and it's bothering
him and it's bothering him for the
conversations that he has with his
girlfriend and then not as a girlfriend
but then his girlfriend with a not as
girlfriend like that back and forth
we've all been there I don't know if
this is going anywhere but I think I
love you but
you know and there's something there's
always some reason why it can't work I
do however agree with you in that scene
when he says you know you want money
I'll give you you know how much money do
you want and there was that moment of
his money was not going to help him
there should have been a beat and the
acting before he goes you know you don't
give people hope you're evil you know
[ __ ] you spider-man it was just kind of
like a lost opportunity to see him go
from troubled kind of tortured guy to
really desperate guy that's a
fundamental problem that I think this
movie has if anything is like there are
times when moments get time to play out
and are very rewarding and then there
are other times where moments get
stunted so that we can long yeah that's
so that's a that's what I felt there was
a lot of that though that one moment
with Aunt May when she's like I'm not
gonna tell you anything about your past
oh well duh yeah I know I start sure I
almost cried like if I got water I feel
that was a great [ __ ] moment but like
everything okay that finale was like
there's a lot of great things about that
finale but you go there's a whole
lecture of it and it's like right after
it I'm like wow this is just cute we're
really just making this all trying to
work right now I felt like they they
could've yeah all right I feel like they
could have preserved green goblin for
part three at least as far as those
kinds of things go like the battle II
things is always like here's a shaky
setup but a payoff I like to like you
know they go to have the electro fight
house like no and then they have the
finale with him and I was like oh cool I
guess the movies wrapping up and then
here comes goblin no but oh well I like
the subsequent scene though okay first
off that moment one died like everyone
knows she's gonna die especially one
[ __ ] subscribers ruin it for you okay
like yeah it's not angry I got [ __ ]
went all electro on everyone in here
okay that when she died I thought hey I
was shot really well yeah yeah like what
did they made that happen
yeah just the physical thing they did
was like wow and I know that's how it
goes
yeah I did too and then they go through
like five months of time all the sudden
and you're like I feel like they could
have preserved this five months a little
bit in the beginning of the part three
and then let all that like the emotional
complexity of it because they're like
yeah spider-man's back
I'm like for the for the people in the
movies we got 4 5 months for us he's
been gone for 10 minutes so it didn't
like move me yeah sure
this movie is full of these things like
that where half of me goes yeah no
totally and the other half goes well but
I guess I get what they had to do like
because I like that sequence just just
as an experience to watch and visually
and with everything I like the way they
did it and I think it's interesting that
they set us up on no no no for sure of
spider-man's gonna be back I think they
would have a harder time ending a movie
on such a sour note because then people
will leave sad and with their giant
Hollywood franchise that they clearly
are concerned we gonna make my does
that's what I mean it's like my weird
feelings about this are every flaw that
I thought this movie had I'm like I kind
of think it also works at the same time
it brought everything back full circle
you know like with the messages you know
the obvious theme displayed at the
beginning of the movie Hey yeah weather
speech and then that that when she gives
this the the graduation speech I still
had a doubt in my mind as to whether
they would actually kill her especially
when they're talking about oxberg in
that moment she gave that speech I was
like yep she's gonna die yeah that whole
thing about life because it can be taken
away that's why it's precious I'm like
you're gonna die you could devote
theoretically a whole movie to Oh Peter
and Harry are actually getting to know
each other again or at least half a
movie and hearing ends up being like a
1/6 of them movie they want to make like
six movies though so it's like if you
want to make like a bunch of movies take
your [ __ ] time a little bit one of
the critics I like said spider-man the
amazing spider-man 2 is the spider-man 3
of spider-man movies which I thought was
really funny quote but I actually
disagree I disagree too I think it's way
better than spider-man 3 there's a lot
going on spyro 3 but at least in this
one what a lots going on it's it's
justifiable at least because you can at
least say like well that's kind of life
of a young adult imagine this guy being
a superhero he's gonna have a lot of
[ __ ] going on you know yeah he's got his
old best friend so it's like what do you
the same thing that I have an issue it's
the same thing where I'm like well it
sort of makes sense why they chose to do
that you didn't see spider-man one the
amazing spider-man Hays and she actually
missed my favorite one spider-man not
the amazing you can see spider-man 2
that's my favorable how did you see
spider-man 3 in US which is a
one-in-three but miss the one that
everyone
can we talk about how they were on top
of the bridge and they're like standing
on this little post I was so scared for
them at that point like I know you're
spider-man but you're gonna follow the
CG I was so good there because I felt
like I was gonna fall off like it was
yeah the way they portrayed max before
it becomes electro I was like this is a
little too cartoony and it's not that
believable - I liked it more as they
went on but at first I was like this
just looks like a Jamie Foxx playing
bunny roll right now
I couldn't just believe max there were
points with his story especially where I
was kind of thinking like how Comic Book
II are you trying to be right now and
and I actually quite like Jamie Foxx
doing that something like I it didn't
feel forced coming from him but I do
agree it took some time to acclimate to
like how funky are you trying to get
right cuz they got all this like cold on
the performance it was like the hair was
just like a little over the top
you know we're just like in case you
didn't know he's like a little like
weird like cuz we gonna make him
weird-looking let's make his hair like
funky and stuff everyone just pushes him
everywhere he goes yeah I think
characters get extra mean yeah yeah
Novak did a good job in that role but
like his his character was like
one-dimensional [ __ ] I looked I liked
how he played it cuz he couldn't I mean
it's interesting but you know what the
thing that I think that that kind of
overshadowed that for me is the fact
that I actually liked how they made him
evil I like that they took that whole
time for him to be in the square being
like I don't know what's going on I'm
freaking out please I'm sorry it's not
me and then the transition cuz I was
like I mean you know you fall in a vat
of eels [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens you get
electrified but you don't just
automatically hate spider-man the way he
becomes a villain I was actually like oh
I like how you transition him from
nebbishy spider-man loving guy into you
know villain but I didn't I didn't feel
for his storyline after he got [ __ ]
like in prison I I really did not like
that moment that you're talking about I
thought was great that whole scene was
absolutely fantastic do you know like
cuz he does disappear for a whole large
part of the
yeah when they brought him back I'm like
it just makes me go this could have been
more of movie because okay you remember
like doc not to keep comparing but
remember like dr. octopus you totally
got where you haven't seen you totally
got where he was coming from even
[ __ ] Willem Dafoe made sense
intellectually instruct technically it's
all there but emotionally I'm just not
with it so I guess that's a fundamental
thing because when it comes to Electro's
grudge with spider-man they give you a
lot more reason to be like no I get with
spider-man ones doing whereas in the
other movies it's like his relationship
Eddie Brock you totally understand why
he hates him you understand what's going
on with norman enough to get why he
hates him yeah and you understand what's
going on with Ock enough like they they
build the two sides equally whereas in
this one it's a little bit like that was
just a misunderstanding and that cop was
[ __ ] up and now he hates fighting you
know like villains are cool villains are
good but I didn't feel that any of them
were really like that's part of the best
things about comic book movies are like
how you fully develop a villain why see
your thoughts I I thought in the
beginning max was kind of boring their
mind knows who he is he's gonna come
back and he must be important when it
came to when he was like it's not my
fault it's not my fault you know I
didn't mean to do this and that whole
scene I was very moved by that i I don't
know how they kept his eyes
so probably ball yeah exactly that's
that's the job you're a hard with the
fact I believed that he would become
this angry on the end because if he's
being tortured I by him going to that
place I guess why he thinks you know if
spider-man's fault cuz spider-man should
have looked out for him and so he needs
someone to blame so you know he's gonna
blame spider-man and also here he comes
and reinforces that so was not satisfied
with how Harry becomes the Green Goblin
when you inject yourself with super [ __ ]
why does it do your hair also and all
these superhero movies they get a haired
makeover when they become an even maybe
they're just kind of like this door open
oh no they're not like come back it's
straight and it's in the transformation
scene his hair it goes
juices came out his follicles and he
kind of like went like this and it
stayed because it worked it like kind of
a Something About Mary thing yeah
they're bits of that that I thought were
cool and handled well in their bits of
that where I was like this is happening
really fast okay when he injected
himself I'm on that [ __ ] I was cool with
that it was when he crawls over to the
green Goblin's yeah reminded me of Iron
Man too when he becomes when ro D
becomes war machine it's like okay I
guess he's war machine now it's the same
thing you're like there was no meaning
behind the suit well yeah that was
another one of those things where I at
least watching it felt like they
probably wanted to put something here
had something here and then just made
the executive decision oh he's gonna get
in the suit regardless we don't have
time to spend with him poking around the
lab for this [ __ ] let's just put him in
the suit because it's the same with the
elec word it's electro get his suit and
what is it well we really did electric
at his suit that bothers me
oh the okay that was the opposite point
it's just it's just details that that
people will notice but we can afford to
lose because it's like he can get a suit
you know well they I mean they they
addressed it early on in the mood
they're like oh we got this suit though
interface with your nervous system and
make you a super soldier and I feel like
to save time they just went remember
that suit that he was eventually gonna
find let's just put it right in front of
him right now yeah yeah I thought the
green goblin did look cool it has a lot
of those moments where like that that
electrified ends and then it's like oh
here comes Green Goblin to pad out the
top oh but he looks pretty good I like
what he's doing to look like then the
cool scene I like how we learned that it
was Peter in that moment you know he
just looks like a wedding I like that
this movie has a lot of us is good but
I'm back in baby ah no I'm getting lost
again but I'm back I had that same
reaction a bunch of times I was like
here we go with ending number three
that's pretty cool though alright do
this I'm there here we go with more
story life but actually getting into it
okay